you know it was a scary time in my life
for sure demi lovato reveals she wasn't
sure if she'd ever perform again
following her overdose on Thursday the
ne1 singer sat down with Andy Cohen on
Sirius XM's radio Andy and opened up
about the Grammys the Superbowl and her
recent return to music which she said
wasn't a given I think as time goes on
I'll be able to give more information or
more details and things like that but
just in a general eye it was a general
diet we didn't know what was gonna
happen we didn't know how healthy I
would be when I left and you know it was
a scary time in my life for sure et was
with Andy Cohen on Friday and he said
that the revelation had him shook what
surprised me was that she said that
there was a moment in the hospital where
she was listening to the song that she
sang at the Grammys and she thought if I
ever come back to music and singing in
life performing this is the song I'll
sing and I it struck me that there was a
moment where she thought she may not
come back to life performing that's how
heavy and serious it was for her
Demi released the track during her
Grammys performance on Sunday and told
Andy the song represented a cry for help
she recorded it just four days before
her July 2018 overdose that song I knew
that it represented that period in my
life when everything hit the fan like I
knew that it represented exactly what I
was going through the vulnerability I've
never had a moment like this you know
where I've stood next to a piano and
sang my heart out you know I've never
had one of those moments on like an
award show and I thought you know if I
ever come back from this because I was
still in the hospital I didn't know and
I thought if I ever come back from this
so I want it to be at the Grammys and I
want it to be this song
Demi's performance at the awards show
was so powerful and emotional she had to
restart just moments into the song quote
I think I was just overwhelmed and
overtaken by emotion also it was very
much in my head like this is the first
time you're onstage in a year and a half
I put myself back in that hospital bed
listening to that song on little
speakers in the ICU I put myself back in
that position and I was just overwhelmed
he seems very positive and that song is
he it is a truth bomb it's incredible
and her return to music is about to get
a super treatment because she's
performing the national anthem at the
Super Bowl
on Sunday and guys she's nervous
Demi says she's very excited nervous but
also grateful and she says she's gonna
steer clear of reading the comments
after it's all said and done
she's staying off social media way and
she not she's learned to not take the
comments good or bad from people and
make her feel any sort of way because
she knows that it's all kind of fake and
she is trying to surround herself with
her close friends with your her support
group so I thought that was very
positive but it wasn't all Super Bowl
and Grammy chatter we had a very frank
conversation about her bisexuality and
the way that her parents view it Demi
also opened up about her experience
coming out to her parents as sexually
fluid well I'm still figuring it out huh
like I didn't officially tell my parents
that I saw myself being ending up with a
what possibly with a woman - until like
2017 how does it weigh it was actually
like emotional but really beautiful and
um and I'm after everything was done I
was like shaking and crying and I've
just felt overwhelmed Demi's biological
dad Patrick died in 2013 but she
explains publicly that she considers her
mom diana and her stepdad Eddie to be
her parents I have such incredible
parents they were so supportive my dad
was like yeah obviously it's like well
okay
hello cool for the summer but my mom my
mom was the one that I was like super
nervous about but she was just like I
just want you to be happy I've had a
Demi shaped hole in my heart and it
feels so good to have her back healthy
happy and doing what she does best of
course you can count on et to bring you
all the latest on Demi and her Super
Bowl performance so make sure to keep it
locked right here
until next time I'm Hallie Stevens see
you soon